une pause détente en plein montigny le
bretonneux une journée consacrée au yoga
était organisée ce dimanche 24 novembre
au complexe sportif pierre de coubertin
ce rendez vous gratuit a été lancé par
la ville
nous avons commencé en 2016 à montigny
le bretonneux et nous l'offrons chaque
année nous essayons de le faire avec
l'eau sous le haut patronage de
l'ambassade de l'inde
et c'est un moyen aussi d'offrir un
moment de bien-être à nos aliments tard
la séance s'est déroulée sous les yeux
de quatre associations spécialisées dans
le yoga objectif évacuer le stress à
travers des postures sportive alliant
force physique et souplesse des
bienfaits de cette pratique de yoga
c'est une philosophie de vie et c'est
une meilleure connaissance de soi
l'événement affiché complet avant la
séance au total une centaine de
personnes s'est inscrite pour cet
événement c'était la première fois que
je faisais ça et c'est une découverte
pour moi quoi parce que c'est vraiment
quelque chose de une grosse détente
au niveau du corps détendu ça fait du
bien encore au corps et à l'esprit
on sent vraiment quand on a des tensions
et quand on écoute bien le page dire l
intervenante
effectivement vous arrivez à vous
détendre sans pour autant avoir
d'expérience donc je pensais avec
l'expérience doit faire vraiment bien
depuis sa création son rendez vous a
également permis de faire la promotion
du yoga dans la ville depuis la rentrée
tous les cours organisés dans la commune
affiche presque complet et vu
l'engouement suscité cette année
l'effervescence devrait continuer